vuelven las protestas a las calles de
puerto príncipe y de nuevo es para pedir
la renuncia del presidente joven el mois
según la oposición y gran parte de la
sociedad civil
moix debía dejar el cargo este 7 de
febrero con eso desde hoy ya no
reconocemos a yo en el mois en el
palacio nacional porque su mandato
terminó
la iglesia haitiana y el poder judicial
también consideran que debe renunciar
sin embargo a raíz de una interpretación
distinta de la constitución
moix asegura que le queda un año en el
poder y tiene el apoyo de washington y
de la organización de estados americanos
además 23 personas fueron detenidas el
domingo acusadas de planear un golpe de
estado entre los cuales se encuentra un
juez de la corte suprema y una alto
cargo de la policía
cote que que planificación porque
planeaban arrestar al presidente obama
para la nacional que planeaban invadir
el palacio para instalar un presidente
provisional que ya tenía su discurso
preparado de ella
de hecho la oposición llevaba semanas
hablando de su intención de hacer una
transición de poder con un presidente
interino que sustituyera a moix sin
embargo parece que por ahora el
presidente seguirá en el cargo a pesar
de que las calles de la oposición piden
su renuncia desde hace años
bajo su mandato haití ha atravesado
fuertes crisis de seguridad un
incremento de secuestros graves
problemas de suministro energético y
altos índices de corrupción